[Musica]
un miliardo di anni fa in una regione
molto remota dell'universo due buchi
neri due oggetti giganteschi del cosmo
si avvicinarono lentamente in una danza
mortale e finirono per fondersi l'uno
nell'altro provocando delle onde delle
perturbazioni nel tessuto stesso dello
spazio e del tempo delle onde di gravità
nel settembre 2015
queste onde che hanno attraversato
l'universo per un miliardo di anni sono
state registrate qui sulla terra da due
strumenti che fanno parte di un unico
esperimento largo negli stati uniti e
poi sono stati registrati ancora da
altri eventi cosmici anche da altri
strumenti
recentemente anche dallo strumento
italiano virgo vicino pisa
questa scoperta che era stata predetta
da albert einstein cento anni fa è una
scoperta che ci apre un mondo nuovo un
universo tutto da scoprire ed è per
questo che ha avuto il premio nobel per
la fisica quest'anno questa è una di
quelle scoperte che ci avvicinano a
quello che non conosciamo
quello che non conosciamo è molto più
importante di quello che conosciamo già
e in questa piccola breve avventura
attraverso la scienza insieme a me vi
farò capire perché quando avevo 6 anni
sognavo di fare l'astronoma poi però mi
interessavano anche altre cose ad
esempio il teatro infatti il mio primo
ruolo è stato comunque legato
all'astronomia perché facevo la stella
cometa in uno spettacolo natalizio la
mia carriera ha preso altre strade
e alla fine però sono finita nel posto
giusto per vivere in diretta l'avventura
della scienza e per coltivare ancora la
mia passione per la scienza al cern a
ginevra per fare l'assistente personale
del direttore generale dell'epoca un
premio nobel per la fisica italiano oggi
la scienza non la faccio non sono una
ricercatrice ma la racconto la racconto
a tutti sono una comunicatrice
scientifica e la racconto come
un'avventura documentandola non solo dal
cern che comunque la mia base ma anche
da posti molto estremi come l'antartide
che vedete in questa fotografia qui sono
comune
colonia di pinguini di adelia oppure
l'artico basi spaziali e anche da
deserti aridi simi altissimi questo il
deserto di atacama sulle ande cilene
dove esiste un osservatorio astronomico
fantastico alma 60 antenne che fanno
radioastronomia e vedono segnali che
arrivano da un diverso lontanissimo sono
segnali sud millimetrici dello spettro
elettromagnetico noi con i nostri occhi
vediamo una piccolissima parte i
telescopi riescono a vedere dai raggi
gamma che sono molto potenti fino alle
onde più deboli ecco alma è il primo e
unico strumento che vede queste onde
sublime trick e che ci portano segnali
da universo lontanissimo e che ci aprono
ancora un'altra finestra su quello che
non conosciamo
ma torniamo al cern ha la mia base il
più grande laboratorio scientifico al
mondo
qui si studia la scienza più
fondamentale di tutte la fisica delle
particelle elementari quella che ci dice
di cosa è fatto all all'estremo tutto
quello che esiste dalle nostre cellule
dall'aria che respiriamo questo palco i
pianeti lo spazio interstellare tra noi
e le altre stelle e tutto l'universo si
studia a livello più piccolo della
materia e le forze che lo tengono
insieme il cielo è stato creato nel 54 a
12 stati membri europei per far
riguadagnare all'europa il primato in
fisica che aveva perso con la guerra
mondiale ma anche per incoraggiare una
collaborazione pacifica fra i popoli ed
oggi la conquista più grande del cern è
proprio quella di essere una cittadella
globale della scienza dove si lavora
pacificamente è una specie di prototipo
di un mondo ideale un mondo dove ci sono
oltre 17 mila persone che arrivano da
tutto il mondo da tutti i continenti
anche da continenti in guerra fra di
loro e sono soprattutto giovani l'età
media 27 anni sono ricercatori in fase
di dottorato o post doc vengono da paesi
appunto che non riconoscono all'altro
neanche il diritto di esistere alcuni di
loro eppure lavorano insieme
pacificamente lavorano perché sono
animati dalla stessa passione per la
scienza da un valore universale che
trascende qualsiasi differenza politica
di credo di etnia eccetera
che cosa vengono a fare al cern ha
adesso facciamo un'altra piccola
parentesi scientifica vengono perché qui
trovano gli strumenti che gli servono
quelli più potenti più grandi per fare
la loro ricerca
questa è un'immagine satellitare della
zona franco svizzera attorno a ginevra
riconosciamo il lago lemano la pista
dell'aeroporto di ginevra e quel cerchio
grande rosso è l'ultimo dei grandi
acceleratori di particelle elementari
che sono gli strumenti che questi
ragazzi usano per capire di cosa è fatto
tutto
guardiamo lo più da vicino questo è l hc
nella stessa zona che si vedeva prima da
satellite riconosciamo sempre comunque
lago la pista dell'aeroporto
abbiamo capito che è uno strumento
enorme 27 chilometri di circonferenza
sottoterra 100 metri nella zoomata
vediamo come è fatto sono ventisette
chilometri di magneti superconduttori
fatti di materiali nuovi inventati non
si compra da nessuna parte o nelle hc si
fa con le menti di tutti messi assieme
ea prestazioni da capogiro
basta dirvi che contemporaneamente il
posto più caldo il posto più freddo
della nostra galassia più caldo perché
al suo interno circa vano fasci di
protoni li vediamo qua nel loro to be a
vuoto che quando vengono in collisione
fra di loro raggiungono una temperatura
100.000 più volte calda di quella del
sole ma per funzionare questi magneti
superconduttori sono raffreddati almeno
275 gradi celsius e quindi una
temperatura così più fredda di così non
c'è fra nel sistema solare
queste collisioni poi sono lette questi
fasci circa 1 paralleli vengono fatti
collidere in quattro punti sono
collisioni che sono lette da altri
strumenti altri strumenti che sono
altrettante squadre di giovani fisici
che li pensano li progettano li
costruiscono e poi li fanno funzionare
3000 fisici in cms 4.000 in at last sono
due grossi esperimenti attorno ai punti
di collisione di lhc che leggono 40
milioni di collisioni al secondo per
vedere cosa è successo
la collisione sono enormi qui vediamo un
essere umano di taglia normale e un
altro al centro del rivelatore atlas
mentre era in costruzione sono cinque
piani di elettronica super sofisticata
innovatrice completamente fatta in
laboratorio da appunto da queste grandi
squadre di soprattutto giovani che
servono a vedere cosa allora molti
pensano che quando i protoni collidono
fra di loro si rompono e vediamo cosa
c'è dentro no non è questo che si fa
negli acceleratori di particelle
particolari collider quello che si fa e
si lanciano questi fasci di protoni ha
un'energia altissima la velocità della
luce quello che succede
questi prodotti non sono più protoni
quando sono in questa condizione sono
energia pura per cui sono scontri di
energia in un punto molto piccolo molto
denso come il tubo vuoto di lhc è quello
che succede quando questa energia si
scontra con un altra energia succede
quello che aveva previsto einstein è
uguale emmeciquadro che l'energia si
trasforma in materia
questo vuol dire la formula più famosa
della scienza che se concentriamo
tantissima energia in un punto
piccolissimo densissimo completamente
vuoto questa energia da vita a materia
questo è successo nel momento del big
bang è così che è nato l'universo per
questo einstein e tanto famoso lo
chiamano l'ingegnere dell'universo
perché ha capito come è nato l'universo
dal big bang
quindi se vogliamo in lhc vediamo stelle
sotto terra vediamo l'universo al suo
inizio un universo molto giovane quanto
giovane non proprio all'inizio ma un
miliardesimo di secondo dopo il big bang
qui arrivato finora lhc e telescopi e
acceleratori di particelle alla fine si
si complementano nel loro lavoro e
abbiamo capito che l'universo a 13,7
miliardi di anni abbiamo capito tutte le
sue fasi
lele hc è l'unico con l'udeur in grado
di studiare la fase primordiale
dell'universo perché perché telescopi
anche se possono vedere tutto lo spettro
elettromagnetico comunque hanno bisogno
di luce la luce altro non è che fotoni
io vedo voi e voi vedete me perché i
fotoni che voi emanate ok mano io
arrivano
nostra retina e creano le immagini del
cervello che vediamo i telescopi sono
solo degli occhi molto più potenti hanno
un range molto grande ma comunque sono
limitati dalla luce e la luce non è nata
subito nell'universo l'annuncio è nata
quando l'universo era 380.000 anni
diretta un universo di 35 a 7 miliardi
di anni e 380mila un universo bambino sì
però come quando si concepisce un
bambino è importantissimo capire il
concepimento dell'universo perché quando
si concepisce un bambino è lì che si
forma e si decide il suo dna e quindi
tutto quello che lui sarà e
nell'universo primordiale si decidono i
mattoni fondamentali gli atomi i nuclei
che poi faranno le stelle e i nuclei che
poi faranno il carbonio il ferro e
quindi la vita quindi importantissimo
capire tutto ma abbiamo detto che
telescopi e gli ha certo di particelle
hanno capito tante cose ma hanno capito
tutto in realtà no quello che non
sappiamo
nonostante tutti questi sforzi questi
strumenti è molto di più di quello che
sappiamo è la dimostrazione è arrivata
negli ultimi anni sempre da l'astronomia
questa è un'immagine presa dal very
large telescope uno dei grandi telescopi
nel deserto di atacama in cile come al
ma non lontano dal e dell immagine di
orbite di stelle all'interno di galassi
che vanno molto più veloce di quanto la
fisica ci direbbe che devono andare
perchè perchè non c'è una massa
sufficiente visibile che giustifichi
questa velocità e allora una delle
conclusioni
questo succedeva circa dieci anni fa
all'inizio si andava un po a spanne e
deve esserci una massa oscura che non
emana non la vediamo ma c'è perché ne
vediamo gli effetti gravitazionali bene
hubble ha visto la stessa cosa ha visto
altre anomalie gravitazionali attorno a
degli ammassi di galassie queste sono
delle stelle la cui traiettoria
completamente deviata sono deformati e
anche lì la massa che si vede non
giustifica questa deformazione e quindi
telescopio dopo telescopio dalla terra
dallo spazio hanno tutti visto queste
grandi deformazioni uno dei telescopi
che le ha viste lo citavo prima il very
large telescope questa una foto presa
dal drone dal mio compagno con cui vado
a fare queste avventure
in giro per il mondo a caccia di scienza
e questa invece un'altra immagine quindi
sono sono misure precisissime indirette
sì perché non vediamo direttamente
questa materia perché non emana nulla ma
sono misure così precise da farne una
mappa sappiamo dov'è questa materia
oscura nel nel cielo nell'universo e
sappiamo tutti gli effetti
gravitazionali che a questa mappa in
particolare è molto potente e molto
recente ha misurato effetti
gravitazionali anomali su 26 milioni di
galassie
quindi la materia oscura la materia che
c'è ma non si vede è una dei tanti i
confini del mondo che non conosciamo e
il problema è uno è un problema grosso è
che di materia oscura ce n'è molta di
più di materia ordinaria quella
ordinaria che ci fa noi e pochissima
rispetto a tutta la materia
dell'universo solo il 4 per cento
quindi noi sappiamo solo il 4 per cento
di quello che c'è il 26 per cento
dovrebbe essere materia oscura il resto
energia oscura un altro grande enigma di
cui meglio non parlare per cui la vera
risposta alla domanda perché è
importante quello che non sappiamo non è
soltanto perché studiando quello che non
sappiamo costruiamo strumenti strepitosi
che ci portano il world wide web che è
stato inventato al cern che ci portano a
risonanza magnetica nucleare la pet ci
portano i telefonini e tutta la
comunicazione moderna che non
esisterebbe senza transistor il transito
non esisterebbe senza le leggi di
maxwell e così la relatività assenza la
relatività non potremmo mai utilizzare
il gps senza le correzioni per la
relatività einsteiniana è importante
perché ci dà tecnologia ma non per tutti
è importante perché sapere solo il 4 per
cento forse un po frustrante per noi
essere intelligenti ma forse c'è anche
chi si accontenta di sapere che quello
che il 4 per cento fatto di atomi il
resto boh no il valore vero che ho
imparato da questa avventura con la
scienza è la lezione che ci danno tutti
questi giovani che lavorano insieme i
campi così difficili che immagino le
costruiscono strumenti complessissimi li
mettono 100 metri sotto terra 5 mila
metri di quota sulle
sul livello del mare è nata cama in
antartide poi fanno dei modelli
complessissimi analizzano petabyte di
dati fanno previsioni precisissime sulla
base di quello che vedono giovani che
vengono a tutti i paesi del mondo
questa è la collaborazione cms ad
esempio lavorano in non in competizione
c'è anche molta competizione fra un
esperimento e l'altro ma non è vera
competizione ecco petizione
collaborazione e competizione insieme è
una cosa estremamente sana loro sanno
valorizzare l'altro loro hanno bisogno
dell'altro hanno bisogno della persona
diversa da loro che ha idee diverse
culture diverse etnie diverse perché
pensa in modo diverso e soltanto pensare
in modo diverso consente a questi
giovani di fare dei passi avanti e
scrivere altre pagine nel libro della
conoscenza senza un'idea innovativa non
possono andare avanti è stato benissimo
che hanno bisogno l'uno dell'altro per
questo dicevo il cern e modello di
ideale di pace e di una città ideale di
come dovrebbe essere il mondo ho
iniziato dicendo che era bambino avevo
un sogno che riguardava le stelle anche
oggi un sogno che riguarda le stelle
quello che sogno oggi è che tra il
trigri e l'eufrate nell'antica
mesopotamia oggi siria iraq iran turchia
e così via
si dovrebbero costruire tanti telescopi
perché ci sono le condizioni ideali come
quelle del deserto di atacama almeno geo
fisicamente sono condizioni ideali
eredità che da dt dezza delle immagini e
poi deserto quindi non c'è luce e non
c'è perturbazione luminosa per questi te
le scopi e poi c'è una grandissima
tradizione perché l'astronomia e
occidentale natali con i sumeri e gli
assiri babilonesi che ci hanno lasciato
tantissime conquiste che ancora oggi
sono utilizzate in astronomia
quindi il mio sogno di bambina è
costruire telescopio in posti come racca
mosul kabul telescopi straordinari che
possano non solo restituire a queste
terre il loro cielo quel cielo che gli
ha fatto nascere l'astronomia ma
soprattutto restituire ai bambini di
queste di queste zone
un futuro migliore grazie
[Applauso]